think of Tommy's arrest is it legal what
was your opinion but I think it's
politically motivated if he was in
contempt of court which he could well be
then why didn't they actually just warn
him it seems to me that we're actually
arresting the wrong people here we're
putting the wrong people in jail many of
us are getting heat off Twitter Facebook
or our social media platforms we're not
given a platform in the mainstream media
and so now for that the judge produced
this court order to say that there's a
media blackout I really hope that the
mainstream media and the alternative
news media are going to challenge this
and I also say so that the hopefully had
a phone Secretary Sajid Javid I hope
that he's going to be looking after
taught me in prison because of course if
he's not we know the person he's in and
the jihadis are in there if one hair on
his head is damaged or he's assaulted
then he's got this whole football lads
Alliance the veterans against terrorism
you kidding from Britain against him
this is a really big growing movement
and I think over there 10 Downing Street
and also the Home Office really
underestimate the strength of feeling
about Tommy being arrested
yesterday but it's not just about Tommy
being arrested it's about all of us it's
big movement for far too long we've all
been quiet for now actually all joining
up is this unprecedented can you think
of some any other case whereby someone
was arrested immediately charged and
sentenced within two hours
general Bassam he's questioning that
today we don't think so and everyone's
saying Tommy won't survive these 13
months and geospatially will yuga
concerns that you won't either
I hope he doesn't spend three days and
what's the likelihood of today's event
having any possible outcome or forcing
politicians institutional maintenance
anyway well where we starts writing them
is in their constituencies okay holding
events here but then we should be
targeted we should be going down to such
a teach others go to situate shape its
constituency we should be going down to
Theresa Mays constituency and
demonstrating down there and just say to
the people in their constituency the
conservative voters these are the laser
voters are you happy with the direction
that the UK is going all he's doing is
highlighting what is happening with
these Pakistani grooming gangs and the
chipped old ex sexual exploitation isn't
it funny that they arrest a man for that
but we still got hundreds of
but these men running around tens of
thousands of thousands of girls that
have been abused in this way they've got
the gun absolutely has it's priority
trial because in the video you know
Tommy was saying do you feel any remorse
and one of the accused rapist was saying
I'm gonna [__] your mom in the fanny
I mean that's shows no remorse yeah you
know but he's just in still standing ok
fine he's going into the courtroom but
why arrest Tommy
we're just highlighting what's happening
in this country and do you think he'll
he'll say of the 13 months sort of will
any of us be able to get him out soon
another lawyers it depends on actually
Theresa May Sajid Javid in the political
world and realize that their seats are
under threat or this all actually is
government's under threat then I think
they'll do something and in the meantime
I think will happen and I fear that he
might be serving 30
okay Thank You Johnny so much